all right let's get into this week's
mailbag if you want to participate you
can email info davidpackman.com remember
that we do get hundreds of emails every
day we feature about eight to ten so
please please please with peace and love
don't get mad if yours doesn't make it
on uh let's jump right into one that is
horrible unfortunately uh really really
bad stuff
why do Jews keep getting expelled asks h
why were you people expelled from 109
countries if you did nothing wrong isn't
that a bit strange if you really think
it over if I got kicked out 109 times
from every shop in the area at what
point should I recognize I'm doing
something wrong not blaming all Jews
David but certainly you people are doing
something wrong there's no anti-Semitism
from me my friends are Jewish but at
what point do we stop pretending that
all Jews are innocent just asking
questions this my friends is a bona fide
bona fide classic
anti-semite and I have Jewish friends
uh do I really need to say more about
that one I'm feeling like the answer is
no so I won't let's continue
a sad message from Brady
Brady from Indiana says hey David my
family and I are in a bit of a situation
all of my family have been lifetime
Republicans but despite that they're all
vaccinated that's good but my sister is
hesitant and refusing to get it due to
misinformation she believes the usual
propaganda surrounding vaccine
misinformation and is even thinking
about taking Ivermectin even though
we've told her the dangers we've tried
talking her out to talking to her about
it but it always ends up in a fighter
argument and I'm kind of at a loss she's
even thinking about quitting her job due
to the mandates it's also hard on the
family because we usually never argue
over stuff like this do you have
suggestions or advice appreciate it love
the show keep up the great work if you
could not show my email if you cover
this that would be great of course of
course of course we are not showing your
email address we never would
um listen here's the um
here's the the thing
I keep going back to the Socratic method
of questioning which is presumably her
beliefs about the vaccine being bad and
Ivermectin being good are coming all
from sources to some degree that she has
a similar relationship to she's chosen
some media sources that say the truth
about the vaccine which she doesn't
believe and yet she's chosen some media
sources that say things about Ivermectin
which she does believe and so often what
I've heard from other viewers is when
you explain to them you're trusting
sources on Ivermectin with the same
arbitrary nature with with your with
which you're not trusting sources about
the vaccine if you get them to come to
the realization that can be useful but
it's tough It's very very tough I don't
know
um
that I have real advice beyond that but
let us know how it goes and I'm sorry
you're in that situation Jeffrey wrote
To Me
and said David I think sometimes you can
be hilarious when you said yesterday I
don't know many race car drivers and you
said Butch Earnhardt I literally laughed
out loud I don't agree with 90 of what
you say but I watch your show every day
and you make me laugh sometimes keep up
the good work thanks for streaming The
Rittenhouse trial even though I'm sure
it cost you in the long run yes we are I
appreciate the kind words we are now
unbanned from twitch we were originally
banned for 30 days due to a gory exhibit
that was displayed on Twitch during our
Written House stream they after 11 days
with no explanation unbanned us and
we're back on Twitch and uh have been
streaming there this week so it's all
it's all very opaque but at the end of
the day we're glad to be back Mark wrote
in about the January 6th alleged Trump
writer who has fled to Belarus entering
the country illegally and now asking for
Asylum
Mark says American in Belarus not a
traitor David it's Mark from Germany I
know the GOP as well as Trump and his
supporters love using the terms treason
and traitor whenever it's politically
convenient with Trump often talking
about the good old days when people were
executed for treason despite Trump never
referring I think means never referring
to a real case of treason I'm now
curious whether the political right will
call the capital attacker who's avoiding
Justice by illegally entering and
seeking asylum in Belarus a traitor too
in my opinion this is a perfect example
of treason if we follow the usual
right-wing Narrative of course the
people saying Law and Order the people
saying due process the people saying all
those things uh should be saying wait a
second the Trump writer who fled to
Belarus was charged under the law was
being afforded due process is wrongly
claiming that he's going to be tortured
and all that the the prosecution is
illegitimate and has decided to flee and
illegally enter a different country
they're not saying it because they don't
actually care their principles are only
their principles as far as they're
convenient to them and when the
principles are no longer convenient they
abandon them but of course mark from
Germany is a hundred percent correct
this is kind of funny every once in a
while I get an email
that makes me wonder whether I've lost
my mind Colin wrote to me when I asked
last week about can you help me find the
show in which I did an Alex Jones
impression and Colin says I think the
caller is referencing your Nixon
impression from a few days back
unless I have completely lost my mind I
have not done a Nixon impression on this
program at least for years maybe never
and when I see this like from Colin who
says the caller is referring to your
Nixon impression I start to wonder
whether I've lost my mind but we checked
we looked I definitely didn't do a Nixon
impression I don't know what it's all
about but it's interesting Brett wrote
in about covid boosters and says hey
David considering how many Amer
considering many Americans receive their
second coveted shot in April and May and
it appears we need a booster shot at six
months should we expect a rise in
breakthrough cases over the next month
well we don't have to wonder Brett we
are seeing it we are seeing a
significant increase in cases in the
United States now I just got my third
dose so weekend and a half ago
and I'm glad that I did the question has
been is it every six months or does the
third dose provide longer protection so
far we have good looking data from
Israel which seems to say with a third
shot
the protection lasts longer it doesn't
seem to start to wane at six months now
that's what it seems like right now
the virus can evolve it can change Etc
and then a lot of these
beliefs can change but right now cases
are going up and what's really crazy is
there are more people in the U.S right
now getting third shots than getting
first shots in other words
a bunch of the people now showing up as
getting doses are already vaccinated to
some degree and that doesn't bode
particularly well for our path towards
herd immunity so that's not uh that's
not good we talked about Ron DeSantis
earlier this week and Matthew wrote In
and said hey David why should we be
scared of Ron DeSantis he seems like a
regular corporate Republican not a
trumpist at least when I see him speak
it's just regular Republican talking
points not necessarily trumpist things
I'm sure if he becomes president they'll
disagree with a lot of his policies and
sure he's an ass but why should we be
scared he'll destroy our democracy like
Trump did if he became president I
completely completely disagree with
Matthew Ron DeSantis is a very trumpian
Republican he has a lot of Donald
Trump's worst instincts to do the
opposite of what the sign says on covid
to push these big lies about election
fraud and he announced a few weeks ago
he's opening a commission or something
to investigate election fraud it's like
no nobody Trump won Florida nobody's
even calling into question Florida he is
Bonkers out of his mind but horrifyingly
he is more competent than Donald Trump
so I completely disagree that Ron
DeSantis is just kind of a regular
Republican if you look at Mitt Romney
and Ron DeSantis there's very little in
common very very little not I'm not
praising Mitt Romney I'm just stating a
fact there is no comparison between
DeSantis and real non-trump Republicans
like Mitt Romney uh the late John McCain
the late Colin Powell and others and
we've got to be very very scared if Ron
DeSantis is the 2024 nominee
Aaron says about Kyle Rittenhouse Kyle
is a depreciating political commodity
regardless of the trial outcome Kyle is
a depreciating political commodity that
will end up worthless after his two
weeks of Fame are over he will never
have a substantive Career One Google
search will destroy his chant any chance
he has of making anything of himself
well unless it's in right-wing media and
right-wing agitation I do agree that
after the not guilty verdicts from last
week written house is definitely getting
his 15 minutes of fame appearing on Fox
News
being flown all around and he's
definitely getting some Fame right now I
do agree that in terms of getting a
normal job working as if he ever
actually becomes an EMT or whatever it
seems he's got an uphill climb ahead of
him but I wouldn't be shocked if
writtenhouse ends up being a successful
Firearms YouTuber I wouldn't be shocked
if Rittenhouse ends up as a CPAC speaker
um in that space in that space I
actually think he probably does have a
future now that he's being lionized and
being made a hero out of but I do think
that his usefulness will be quite
limited to that
um and I'm curious to see I mean by
January how many people are talking
about him I don't know we're gonna wait
and see Jeremy wrote in and said hey
David can't Joe Biden use an executive
order to pass the original 3.5 trillion
dollar build back better plan regards
Jeremy no my research is that he cannot
and that something like uh uh the 3.5
trillion dollar build back better plan
needs to go through Congress it relates
to appropriating money and it is not
something that Joe Biden can do via
executive order I don't even know that I
need to say more about it because my
understanding is that cut and dry very
very simple and straightforward if
someone has a different perspective on
that could Joe Biden
Implement elements of buildback better
through executive order maybe let me
know but no my research and we have
looked at it very strongly is uh you
can't pass buildback better via
executive order and lastly today Chris
Rhoden and Chris says thank you this is
just like a nice message we don't get
that many of these thank you hey David
I've been watching your show for a while
I very much appreciate what you do
you've consistently been a voice of
reason in the left-wing space online it
hasn't gone unnoticed that you
understand how the type of content you
put out affects people in real life I
know it would be easy to grab more views
to put out a spicy fouchy video or cover
conspiracies but you understand that
only serves to create more doubt around
the effort to save lives I've had a few
people in my life pass away from
covid-19 and all of them watched
prominent YouTubers or online podcasters
who were quote only asking questions
about covid and the coveted vaccines you
care about your audience and we can see
it your work is invaluable thank you
Chris thank you
I really appreciate that and um you know
it can be very easy to focus on like the
first email that I showed you disgusting
anti-Semitism directed specifically at
me uh and it's great to hear from Chris
I really appreciate that remember that
we are going to be off tomorrow Thursday
for Thanksgiving and Friday for
Thanksgiving we will then be back on
Monday Federal Thanksgiving holiday here
in the United States everybody taking a
much needed break and he will be back
with you Monday but before that there's
the bonus show if you remember at
joinpakman.com come sign up at
joinpakman.com you can get access to the
bonus show
otherwise we'll see you back here on
Monday